-Jenna Lyons,
I can't wait to talk to you
about all of this stuff.
-I'm so excited,
and I love The Roots. Hi!
-Yeah, come on.
We love you right back.
I want to talk to you about --
We just had kid inventors
on the show,
and I know you're very creative.
Do you remember the first time
you designed anything?
-I -- the first time
I designed anything,
I made a watermelon skirt
that was bias cut,
full length to the ground.
And I remember
going into social studies --
I was in seventh grade --
and Darlene Patterson, who was,
like, the hottest girl in --
like, the hottest.
-Oh, really?
-Like, everything.
-Oh, okay, yeah, was --
[ Laughter ]
-And she leaned over,
and she's like,
"Where did you get that skirt?"
and I was like, "I made it."
And then she said,
"Would you make me one?"
And I was like -- pkk!
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
She did it.
-She did it.
Darlene, where are you?
-Darlene, you created
one of our faves, Jenna Lyons.
Remember, we met years ago --
-Of course.
-Thank you.
You helped me out. Yeah.
-I remember.
-Yeah, I -- I had an invention
called the "Pocket Dial."
-Well -- the Pocket Dial?
-I think it was what we --
-No.
-We ended up calling it
the Pocket Dial, I think.
But it was a phone case.
-Yes, but it was brilliant.
-There was a phone -- thank you.
-It really was.
He came in, and he had this
completely insane idea.
And then, actually,
it was kind of not insane.
We put a pocket square
and inserted it onto the top
of a phone case so he could --
-So you could put it
in your pocket, and it'd
look like you were wearing
a little pocket square, but
really it was just your phone.
-I mean, hot.
-Yeah.
-And we sold out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We saved --
We saved a lot of elephants.
-We did!
-We did.
We saved a lot of elephants.
-Oh, that's right.
The Sheldrick Foundation.
-Sheldrick Foundation, correct.
-God, your memory is --
-Yeah.
And you were so cool,
and I was, like, meeting you.
I was nervous to --
-Wait. What?
-You were so cool.
Yes!
'Cause I -- you're famous.
-Come on.
You're kind of more famous
than me.
-No, but you were cool.
[ Laughter ]
And you had these pants --
you had these white pants with,
like, paint splatters on them.
-Yeah, but --
I don't know if you noticed,
but you're Jimmy Fallon.
-No, stop. No, no.
[ Laughter ]
All right, wait.
-What?
-Should I pitch you
another idea?
-Um, okay.
-Yeah. All right.
Ready for this?
-Mm-hmm.
-It's nail polish that you can
only use after you --
your nail polish
already chips off.
So, let me explain.
[ Laughter ]
So, your nail polish chips off.
Instead of taking it all off
and reapplying
a whole new layer,
you use that cracked nails --
nail polish to make another
new look, that's totally
different look,
when you put
the next layer on top.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Pkk! Wow.
Don't answer so fast.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, considering
it's International Women's Day,
I love a man deciding how we
should wear our nail polish.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cymbal crash ]
-Jimmy...
-I didn't say it was for women.
I didn't say it was for women.
Excuse me.
-Did you consult --
-Excuse me.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
Wow.
Getting shade from Jimmy Fallon.
Did you consult with anyone
other than me?
-No, my daughters.
-Clearly.
[ Laughter ]
-My daughters.
-Your daughters.
-I want to talk about this,
'cause during the pandemic,
you launched this -- a brilliant
company called LoveSeen.
-I did.
-Congratulations on this.
-Thank you.
-Fast Company called it
one of the most innovative
beauty companies of the year.
Okay?
Tell us about these, please.
-So, I don't have any eyelashes
of my own,
and so, I was fascinated
with all the women at J.Crew,
the place that you came
when you thought I was cool.
Do you remember that part
that you thought I was cool?
-Oh, my God.
You were so cool.
-He thought I was cool.
-You are the coolest.
-And I noticed that all
the women were getting
eyelash extensions,
which I was into.
But I didn't have any eyelashes.
Then I was watching Huda Beauty
and all of these bloggers
making, like, crazy eyelash
with big, giant --
little beats of makeup.
-Yeah.
-And I was like, "How is that
these women and J.Crew,
who want to have, like,
a really natural look,
are looking and focusing
on eyelashes?"
And then what's on the market,
other than extensions,
is like these really voluminous
drip ones.
I can't wear them.
So I made it my own.
-Yeah.
-So, these are --
I'm wearing these.
This is the Drew.
-Oh, you're wearing them now.
-Well, you know --
-They're called the Drew.
-The Drew --
Oh.
Honestly, you know, you -- oh.
[ Laughter ]
-I have --
I have perfect eyelashes?
-You know, maybe I --
Honestly, yes.
What do you think?
-You want to put one on me?
-Don't you think?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think so.
Do I need the -- really?
Will they work on me?
-I think they're gonna be great.
♪♪
Oh, my God.
Do I get music for this?
-Yeah, you get -- I --
-I don't know if it --
-What do I do?
-Look at my chest.
-Okay.
-I won't tell your wife.
[ Laughter ]
Okeydokey.
I think we got this.
Oh, my God, you --
you're kind of hot, man.
You know?
-Yeah.
Yeah, I feel --
-Okay, let's see.
-Really?
-I think so.
-Does this look good?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not bad?
-I think we should do
the other one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wha--
Just one, I think.
Hi.
Hi, there.
Yeah. This feels great.
-You just really -- I think this
might be, like, a thing.
-It feels natch.
-It does kind of look natural.
[ Laughter ]
It really actually does.
You look great.
-I like it. Thank you.
-What do you guys think?
-You like it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jenna, can we talk to you --
can we talk to you --
-It's coming off.
-Are you -- is it --
-I'm gonna fix this.
-Oh, I thought you were gonna
take it off.
-No!
-You're leaving it on?!
-Oh, my God. Yes.
-I'm going to the Knick game
after this.
It'll be perfect.
-Oh, wait.
I'll do the rest of it.
-This is a big deal.
Andy Cohen, Bravocon, announces
"Real Housewives,
New York City."
Jenna Lyons.
There you are, coming out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you --
-Not the most, like, natural
career change, I know.
-I know. I didn't -- I don't
see you doing this at all.
-Same -- like, same.
Like, I didn't have a job.
-Oh, stop.
Is that right?
-Yeah.
When I left J.Crew, I was like,
"What am I gonna do?"
And then I went on podcasts,
and they asked me if I was --
if I had heard that
there was gonna be a reboot of
"The Real Hou--"
Or, "Rhony," they said.
And I didn't know what
"Rhony" was.
And, apparently,
it was the "Real Housewives."
And they said there's never been
an openly gay woman
on "The Housewives."
And I was like, "Mm."
-Could be something.
Wow.
This is big.
-Okay, everyone's silent.
-This is --
[ Laughter ]
-It's hot, you guys.
Trust me.
-It's good.
It's a moment.
-It is a moment.
And so, I decided that
I was gonna do it.
They posted this picture of me,
like, in with all of the other
woman and said, like,
"What about it?
What do you think?"
And I then D.M.'d Andy, and I
was like, "This is hysterical."
And he's like, "No,
it's actually a good idea."
-Wow.
I think it is a great idea.
Don't you guys think
it's a great idea?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I want to see you.
-No, you don't.
-I do. And are you --
-No, don't.
-Wait. No, are you tough?
Are you tough?
-No, no.
-And you tell it like it is?
And you're fashion,
and you're cool-looking.
-No, I'm like none of the above.
I am literally terrified.
Like, lit-- I don't want --
-Did you film any of it yet?
-I told them, "We're done.
But I still have some interviews
to do."
You can be a guest star
on the next one.
-Yeah, did you --
-I think you should come
and be -- like, actually,
that's what we need.
-Really?
You want me to be --
-We need a --
-A male housewife?
-Somewhere in the --
[ Laughter ]
You already got the lashes.
-I do have --
I do have the lashes.
[ Laughter ]
Do you have a catchphrase?
I remember, at the beginning,
everyone has a cool catchphrase.
-I have one.
-And you turn around
holding an apple or something.
-I have one.
-You do have one?
-I'm not telling.
-Oh, you can't tell.
Of course, no spoilers.
-Here's the thing.
I actually, like --
I'm kind of obsessed
with my tagline,
and I'm not changing it.
And so, a friend of mine,
we were at the Pebble Bar
downstairs, actually.
-Oh, I love Pebble Bar!
-I do, too.
Did you know that Johnny Carson
used to go down there
in the back way.
He left the show,
and he would go down
to the Pebble Bar,
and he never had to go outside.
Do you do that?
-Do you know that I do that?
-Do you?
[ Laughter ]
-I use the Johnny Carson --
-Who high-fives?
Wait. Do you --
[ Laughter ]
-This is so you.
This is why you're gonna be
great for the show.
Jenna Lyons, everybody.
LoveSeen is available at Target.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And "The Real Housewives
of New York City"
premieres later this year!
We'll be right back with
a performance from St. Vincent
and The Roots!
Stick around. You nailed it.